ich fühle mich ein bisschen so als will
ich brot auf meinem kopf hat mopo haare
waschen ohne shampoo funktioniert das
überhaupt
[Musik]
hallo freunde der sonne ich bin es
wieder mal eure chemikerin des
vertrauens heute mit dabei monster
pickel sieht man den geschrieben hab ich
neulich willkommen zu einer folge nicht
chemie hämisch erklärt oder so damit
meine ich wenn ihr jetzt neu im alltag
chemie reduzieren wollt dann weiß ich
dass ihr meint ja ich weiß was du meinst
du dürfte nicht immer als schlechte als
kimi und alles gute als natürlich
verstehen
[Musik]
deswegen möchte ich heute etwas typisch
nicht chemisch ist nämlich lupe nehmen
und ist chemisch erklären oder auch noch
shampoo ist wie gesagt der verzicht auf
konventionelle schampus und ich möchte
euch kurz erzählen wie es überhaupt
hierzu kamen denn jeden tag und
geschichte ist auch erzählenswert ich
habe während unserer web sommerpause ein
selbstexperiment für quarks gedreht
dabei wollte ich plastik in meinem
haushalt reduzieren unter anderem wollte
ich mein shampoo durch eine plastik
freie alternative ersetzt und kam dabei
auf diese haar seife aus dem unverpackt
laden die umstellung auf diese seife
fand ich relativ unproblematisch aber es
geht noch deutlich spektakulärer da habe
ich vorstellen hier ist autorin
bloggerin und eine zero waste queen am
ersten tag meines quarks experiments kam
sie mich zu hause besuchen um sich mein
plastik desaster anzuschauen und mir ein
paar start tipps zu geben denn hier und
ihr mann sind inzwischen absolute pro
star in müll zu vermeiden nicht so
leckeres mitgebracht das ist der müll
von sieben monaten so müller
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht recyclebar
ist von zwei personen meinem mann und
mir und wenn ihr das schon beeindruckend
findet dann freunde setzt euch und hört
sich an wie er sich seit jahren die
haare richtig habe mir dreieinhalb jahre
lang mal daumen dreieinhalb jahre lang
meine haare nur noch mit roten meer
gewaschen falls ihr euch jetzt schon
länger
mit moko befasst dann ist die rocken
methode vielleicht nichts neues für euch
aber für mich als 08 15 chemikerin war
das schon
und der gedanke früher nicht so ekelhaft
ich fand es so ekelhaft irgendwie mir
mehr einzumischen weil ich wusste meine
mutter macht sauerteig und roggenmehl
ich wasser war ihr sauerteig am samstag
dachte oh gott was schmiere ich mir im
haar und ich dachte okay ich hab
eigentlich gemacht ein bisschen um fast
wie sohn der wie so eine kleine
herausforderung mich dass ich mich
selber über winter und auch mal sachen
außerhalb meiner kompressoren mache ihr
habt das wirklich gemacht und war
ziemlich begeistert und ich gebe zu
wenig nicht live aus der nähe mit meinen
eigenen augen gesehen hätte wie schön
ski-ass haare sind dann wäre dieses
video wahrscheinlich nie entstanden also
habe ich mir saadet geschnappt saadet
kennt ihr entweder von reporter wo sie
vor vollem körpereinsatz nicht
zurückschreckt oder von uns von mayrleb
hier ist sie unter anderem selbst
ernannter für die wissenschaft
ich war ein bisschen misstrauisch als
sie mich angerufen hat meyer hat
angerufen und möchte gerne probieren wie
es so ist wenn man sich zehn tage die
haare ohne shampoo wäscht hat aber
natürlich kein bock das selber zu machen
deswegen muss das versuchskaninchen
herhalten
ok habs aber trotzdem mal gemacht für
die wissenschaft deb für die
wissenschaft eine sache ist noch ganz
ganz wichtig und zwar kein vollkorn
roggenmehl neben
die schalen des vollen korn halten
nämlich viele ballaststoffe die sich nur
sehr schwer aus waschen lassen habe das
probiert paar mal und ich krieg das
nicht ausgewachsen ist
danach aus als hätte man ganz ganz
schnell schuppel ich habe das schlechte
gefühl ist meine kopfhaut schade kümmert
sich also um die praxis und ich um die
theorie you find ja diese arbeitsteilung
eigentlich ganz dankbar
aber es gibt zu rocken mail shampoo
keinerlei wissenschaftliche literatur
aber was ich machen kann sind educated
guess ich kann also aus sicht einer
chemikerin schauen was logisch ist und
was nicht und unter diesen disclaimer
gehen wir zur ersten frage nämlich was
ist denn in rocco mail drin dass eine
reinigende wirkung haben könnte bei
konventionellen shampoos oder auch bei
meiner unverpackten haar seife dreht
sich alles nur um eins nämlich um
tenside tensiden habe ich inzwischen
jetzt schon einige videos gemacht
verlinke ich euch alles hier nur ganz
kurz tenside bilden sogenannte b-zellen
die fed teilt und schmutz einschließen
so kann das ganze mit dem wasser
weggewaschen werden ohne tenside gibt es
nicht genügend interaktionen zwischen
dem schmutz und dem feld und im wasser
stellt euch vor auf molekularer ebene
haben die wassermoleküle keine
möglichkeit den schmutz oder das fett zu
greifen und mitzuziehen neben den seifen
die man herstellt gibt es auch natürlich
vorkommende tenside in der indischen
waschnuss in der rosskastanie und in
efeu sind zum beispiel sabine enthalten
die man genauso wie seiten auch fürs
waschen verwenden kann in roggenmehl
sind aber keine sabine oder andere team
sieht artige moleküle drin wir haben
also kein tensid und trotzdem
funktioniert es irgendwie ich muss
gestehen langsam vertraue ich dem ganzen
irgendwie ich meine ich meine haare
abends und jetzt ist quasi der zweite
morgen seitdem ich sie das letzte mal
gewaschen hat und sie sehen voll normaal
aus also sich denn ab wie immer das
können sie gut aber sie sehen aus wie
mit einem shampoo auf als ich wieder
eine haare sie sonst anfühlen ja die
sind ja so ein bisschen trocken in den
spitzen aber ich find auch dass sie
nicht groß anders aussehen als suns
verstrubbelt wie immer rock mail besteht
so 73 prozent aus kohlenhydraten genauer
gesagt aus stärke und stärke hat eine
praktische eigenschaft für die
haarpflege nämlich sie absorbiert fed
deshalb wird stärker auch im trockenen
shampoos eingesetzt außerdem hat stärke
noch eine wichtige eigenschaft sie lässt
sich mit wasser mischen sie löst sich
zwar nicht wie salz oder zucker aber im
gegensatz zu öl lässt sie sich
wenigstens im wasser verteilen das liegt
an den molekularen aufbau durch stärke
moleküls all diese ohg oha versteht sich
immer super mit h2o mit dem
wassermolekül stellt euch einfach ein
bisschen so vor als könnten die
wassermoleküle sich an diesen oha
gruppen an dem stärke molekül festhalten
und andersrum
wasserstoffbrückenbindungen sagt man
dazu meine theorie also stärke
absorbiert fett und schmutz und das
ganze wird dank
wasserstoffbrückenbindungen mit dem
wasser weggewaschen okay aber warum muss
man jetzt rocken wir nehmen warum nimmt
man nicht einfach eine stärke ich nehme
an das ist alles eine frage der
sogenannten rio logi zur geologischen
eigenschaften eines materials gehören
dinge wie verformbarkeit oder vlies
verhalten mischungen aus stärke und
wasser sind eine der beliebtesten vor
für experimente handelt man die mischung
langsam und vorsichtig ist sie relativ
dünnflüssig sieht man aber mit schnellen
bewegungen druck auf erstarrt die
mischung das ist zwar sehr cool aber
fürs haarewaschen denkbar unpraktisch
also entweder würde die soße über
hinlaufen oder es will dann beim
einmassieren lokal total test werden
mehl hingegen enthält neben stärke auf
proteine und ballaststoffe die
verhindern dass dieses phänomen auftritt
mal was ich alles tun fühlt sich gut
aber warum rocken
warum nicht weizenmehl weizenmehl hat ja
fast jeder zu hause trocken mail ist ja
schon eher seltene auch das erkläre ich
mit geologie weizenmehl enthält gluten
was ich hier schon mal erklärt haben
blut ihn setzt sich zusammen aus zwei
proteinen
lassen den bbi an ihn und den blutigen
die erst zusammenfinden wenn man wasser
hinzu gibt und sich dann verbinden eine
art kleber bilden deswegen nennt man tut
ihn auch das kleber protein es hält den
teig zusammen und sorgt in weißbrot für
diese schöne queen's organ mail enthält
kein tun dafür mehr von so genannten can
tho saanen in tucson sind schleimstoffe
sie binden wasser und sorgen auch für
einen gewissen klebeeffekt durch diese
unterschiedlichen klebe stoffe haben
weizen und roggenmehl auch
unterschiedliche geologische
eigenschaften denn man sie mit wasser
mischt weizen mais und weizen und wasser
ist bis klassisch das bedeutet wenn man
den teig dehnt zieht er sich wieder in
seine ursprüngliche form zurück
rogan trocken mit wasser ist plastisch
wenn man den teig dient oder verformt
bleibt also das bedeutet roggenmehl
teilt lässt sich leichter auf dem kopf
verteilen als weizen meter jetzt muss
das quasi wie ganz normales shampoo
range lieben werden
es gehört also es ist wirklich sehr sehr
ungewohnt verein zieht es auch ein
bisschen merkwürdig aus ist halt so eine
graue masse irgendwie du vorher so
anrührend und es fühlt sich auch
wirklich komisch an wenn du es in die
haare macht es ist dann erstmal also ich
find das hat sich so trocken angefühlt
und auch halt irgendwie so mehlich und
teigl ich natürlich die macht der medien
deine haare ist für mich ein bisschen so
als würde ich brot auf meinem kopf wer
sich noch etwas gönnen möchte kann seine
haare anschließend einer sauren rinse
unterziehen
ein esslöffel apfelessig mit 300 bis 500
millilitern wasser so eine mischung hat
einen ph wert um die fünf das ist im
selben bereich wie der ph wert unserer
haut und kopfhaut sofern alles gut
versuche sich zu schulen
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass dieser
weichmacher effekt etwas damit zu tun
hat dass ein tieferer ph-wert
kalkablagerungen auslöst das kennen wir
auch vom kalkreiniger auch der ist
leicht sauer
kaum hatte ich dieses seg den haaren hat
sich alles um das thema viel weicher der
welt schon ein bisschen positiver
gestimmt und jetzt nach dem duschen die
ich auch jetzt schon gar nicht mehr nach
essig ich hatte wirklich große große
sorge dass es jemand merkt weil ich
musste direkt arbeiten gehen an dem tag
danach und saß auch wirklich drei tage
in seinem ganz kleinem raum mit einem
team zusammen und dachte mir super wenn
ich jetzt nach essig stinke dann
friedlich da hochkant raus aber es ist
niemandem aufgefallen wirklich niemandem
eine kollegin hat mich sogar nach einer
woche befragt so jamann fängst du denn
eigentlich dein haar experiment an und
ich sehe schon fast fertig es ist ein
gutes zeichen ist glaube ich niemandem
aufgefallen sie liegt natürlich nicht
mehr so schön das shampoo es gibt jetzt
noch nichts eigentlich ist nicht gerade
sehr neutral und ich mag eigentlich
dieses shampoo geruch das ist ein
bisschen blöd aber die griechen ja auch
nicht schlecht reden willst du dir kein
zwang muss davon ausgehen dass ein
konventionelles shampoo mit tensiden
schmutz und teilt deutlich gründlicher
entfernt als rocken will shampoo
allerdings wird der tag ja auch nicht
zum spaß produziert für unsere haut
sondern zum schutz auch dermatologen
raten davon ab täglich mit seife zu
tauschen oder sich die haare zu waschen
nur seine hände sollte man sich
regelmäßig und gründlich mit seife
erschrocken wie shampoo funktioniert
nicht nur in der praxis sondern macht
zumindest in der theorie auch sinn also
ich find als fazit kann man festhalten
dass jeder der irgendwie probleme mit
der kopfhaut hat oder ein bisschen
weniger plastik verbrauchen möchte der
kann es auf jeden fall mal ausprobieren
das ist nicht schlimm auch wenn sie
stimmen hört nur was mit dem roggenmehl
in der abflussleitungen genau passiert
das bleibt auch eine offene frage aber
falls ihr erfahrungen mit note habt auch
irgendwelche anderen schreibt sie gerne
in die kommentare
und falls ihr noch andere nicht
chemische sachen für mich habt die ich
bei chemisch prüft
oder erklären kann schreibt die
ebenfalls in die kommentare und in der
end card hat satte noch etwas für euch
einige stärker und jetzt musst du deine
haare aber von den kurzen töten wollen
sie holten schön läuft die kamera die
stylistin dass du in diese richtung und
dann dabei so den kopf so den kopf
schüttelt ich sehe nur teile von dir
aber ich versuche es bereits
[Musik]